une enquête de public aura lieu sur la
mort d'alain magloire qui a été abattu
sous les balles des policiers lundi à
montréal
la coroner catherine rudel-tessier va
examiner les interventions d'urgence
auprès des personnes atteintes de
problèmes de santé mentale
françois cornut au coeur du tourbillon
au coeur d'une semaine éprouvante un bon
codage appris la nouvelle on me
communiquer la nouvelle j'ai eu comme un
frisson pierre magloire a appris que le
coroner en chef ordonne la tenue d'une
enquête publique sur la mort de son
frère allait magloire souffrait de
problèmes mentaux
il est mort lundi lors d'une
intervention policière
je suis content parce que les décès
d'alain ce propos envers puis je pense
qu'on réalise qu il faut changer
d'attitude envers la maladie mentale
avec l'itinérance karl en quête de la
coronaire ira plus loin les services
d'urgences peuvent-ils améliorer leur
façon de faire devant une personne qui
éprouve des troubles mentaux
le cas d'al et magloire n'est pas unique
c'est quand même 33 mille appels par
année je sens santé mentale on parle
d'une centaine d'appels par jour
le chef de police de montréal ne veut
pas se prononcer sur la décision du
coroner en chef
il rappelle que des centaines de
policiers sont formés pour intervenir
dans de telles circonstances
selon lui il faut aussi agir en amont
c'est trouver des solutions avec
l'ensemble des acteurs de façon
proactive de pendant qu'on se voit
toujours devant une intervention
policière musclée parce que la personne
est en crise je commenterai pas lankais
puis commet très peu rien en ce sens on
va laisser le système faire son travail
si le maire denis coderre ne s'avance
pas le ministre de la sécurité publique
reste tout aussi prudent
je pense que cette enquête pourra
effectivement contribuer à cette
réflexion de la part des autorités
publiques
pierre magloire espère des résultats
concrets pas juste des écrits est-ce que
ça va être un autre rapport qui va être
table était comme les autres rapports
depuis 2011 3 itinérants ont été abattus
par les policiers de montréal ici
françois cormier radio-canada m'ont rien